now a british belgian teenager has
become the youngest woman ever to fly
solo around the world after a five
months journey zara rutherford is back
on terra firma in belgium we'll be
speaking to zara in just a minute
but first a look at her record-breaking
time in the air
there was no cabin crew on board to
prepare for this landing
as 19 year old zara rutherford touched
down in belgium
she became the youngest woman in history
to fly solo around the world and the
youngest person to do so in a micro
light aircraft
[Applause]
a hero's welcome awaited her
i'm really happy to be here it's been a
crazy trip five months long and even
this last fight was pretty tricky so
even yeah it's been a challenge the
whole way through
rutherford's around the world right
spanned five continents and covered 52
000 kilometers she raised money through
sponsorship and often stayed with host
families
zara shared the highs and lows of her
adventure online
the trip took much longer than expected
and there were moments of turbulence
right now my my v
russian visa has just expired so i'm
actually not allowed to go into the
country which is frustrating north korea
is over that way
i'm not allowed to get too close to it
because they don't like small airplanes
flying around i'm really happy on the
ground to be honest
the first
little bit was fine and then suddenly
the clouds started getting lower and
lower i think at the at one point i was
at 600 feet above the ocean which was
pretty scary
beyond breaking records zara had a
bigger mission
meeting locals and giving talks along
the way she tried to inspire other girls
and young women to get involved in
aviation science and technology
back on belgian soil that work continues
growing up i didn't see many other
female pilots i'm kind of hoping to be a
friendly face
and yeah i've gotten some amazing
messages from both girls and women just
saying that they've started flying after
seeing what i've been doing which is
really good do you think you achieved
your mission i think so i like to think
so yeah
it was an emotional reunion for zara's
mother beatrice who says there were some
nail-biting moments of course this is
not without risk
she is breaking a record after all but
but i was very confident in zara's
skills and her experience and also in in
the team
and the whole team behind her and that
we kept it as safe as possible
[Music]
barely out of high school
zara rutherford plans to keep her feet
on solid ground for now and apply for
university
but she hopes her double world record
will encourage girls everywhere to
spread their wings in any way they can
and i'm now more than delighted that
zara found the time to talk to us
there she is sarah congratulations first
of all welcome uh to gw and the first uh
my first question of course how do you
feel today
i'm super happy yeah thank you for
having me it's really strange being back
home and see my family again
i can imagine that you were away for
five months you covered 50 000
kilometers in your own tiny plane i must
say
tell us about the scary moments you you
had in the air there must have been some
yeah definitely i think one of the most
challenging moments was flying over
siberia because it's like minus 35
degrees celsius on the ground and these
were very long flights where i'd go for
hundreds of kilometers without seeing
anything human no roads no electricity
cables no villages obviously no people
and so if the engine stops then suddenly
i am hours away from rescue
and i don't know how long i can survive
in -35 degrees
yeah that is indeed scary um what were
the highlights
i'd say some of the highlights were
again flying inside there probably and
just these very remote places in siberia
um i
had to
avoid north korean airspace but that was
a really interesting flight on its own
and
then taiwan is beautiful saudi arabia is
very beautiful as well so some of these
some of the longer more challenging
flights were also obviously the most
rewarding and
also yeah the yeah the most amazing
so
tell us
what made you plan that trip in the
first place you just didn't wake up one
morning and said they're gonna fly
around the world did you
right no not quite so i'd always dreamt
of doing something crazy and flying
around the world but i never thought
it'd be possible so i always thought
it'd be too dangerous too expensive too
complicated so i never really thought
twice about it but then i was finishing
school and i thought actually this is
the perfect time to do something crazy
when i've got a year to do nothing
basically and fly around the world so i
plan my route i got sponsorship icdsoft
a web hosting company from bulgaria came
on board to help out and i basically
started flying around the world
quite an amazing story what did your
friends and family say when you
approached them with this idea
my
father was super excited my mother was a
bit more nervous
and my friends i think they had a moment
of weight what are you doing
but uh but i mean they've all been
really kind and obviously very
supportive and they're all very excited
also to see me again so i'm really
looking forward to seeing my friends
again
well you said that your aim was to
inspire especially girls to get involved
into science uh and maybe even aviation
what's your message to uh all those
girls out there uh right now
that's right growing up i didn't see
many other female pilots and i was also
that was quite discouraging so i'm
trying to be a friendly face and
so if you're a guy like flying you're
not the only one i'm here too and just
keep going it's uh very rewarding flying
is amazing and you get to see some
pretty cool stuff from there
so last question what what are the next
steps there for you professionally are
you aiming to become a professional
aviator
right now i'm i'm not sure at all so
before this trip i was very certain
about what i was going to do when i was
going to do it now i'm kind of going
with the flow i would love to keep
flying and i will keep flying but a huge
dream of mine is to also
become an engineer and and get an
engineering degree
we wish you good luck with that zara
rutherford there in brussels an aviation
pilot in her own right thank you very
much